-Salut Romain, ça va?
"Huk" de hoquet
- Bah... Qu'est-ce qu...
- Ah...
"Huk" de hoquet
- ATTENTION DERRIÈRE TOI, JEAN-MARC MORANDINI !!
- Bah ça marche d'habitude...
"Huk" de hoquet
Vous avez sans doute déjà été atteints de myoclonies phrénoglottiques
Plus connue sous le nom de "Okay" (hoquet)
Quand on a le hoquet, il se passe deux phénomènes
"Huk" de hoquet
D'abord, nos muscles respiratoires c'est-à-dire notamment le diaphragme
se contractent brutalement et ça a pour conséquence d’expulser tout d'un coup l'air qu'on a dans les poumons
"Huk" de hoquet
Bon ok, mais normalement, quand on expire même très fort ça ne fait pas ce genre de bruits
donc qu'est-ce qu'il se passe?
Eh ben, dans le même temps, l'épiglotte, là, juste au fond de la gorge se contracte pour empêcher l'air d'entrer
Ça fait vibrer les cordes vocales et ça provoque ce bruit caractéristique :
"Huk" de hoquet
On connaît mal le mécanisme exact mais il concerne notamment le nerf phrénique qui innerve le diaphragme
et les nerfs pneumogastriques qu'on appelle aussi les nerfs vagues.
En cas de hoquet ces nerfs seraient "excités" pour diverses raisons : parce qu'on mange trop et trop vite par exemple
- Oh mais regarde-le ce petit glouton là... Oh mais ça se bâfre mmmh!
Il y a d'autres situations dont elles supposent qu'elles "excitent" aussi...
bon on va dire qu'elles irritent aussi les nerfs en question
Comme par exemple quand on boit trop d'alcool ou trop de boissons gazeuses
Mais il y a aussi d'autres causes comme : le tabac, le stress, les changements brutaux de température,
le rire, la toux, les émotions, les conversations de vestiaire de Donald Trump
Bref...
Attention, là on parle du hoquet bénin hein, le hoquet aigu... d'ailleurs celui qui arrive de temps en temps et qui dure pas trop longtemps
même si... bon... ça peut être pénible quand même...
Mais le hoquet peut durer aussi plus de 48 heures, voire plusieurs jours, voire plusieurs semaines
Dans ces cas-là, il faut voir son médecin, ça peut avoir une origine un peu plus sérieuse qu'un gros DoMac avalé en 2 secondes
Mais ça se soigne
Le reste du temps, pour faire passer un simple hoquet,
les trucs habituels, c'est-à-dire les remèdes de Grand-mère si vous voulez
ça consiste à obliger le diaphragme à arrêter ses petites simagrées :
en faisant monter le taux de CO2 dans le sang par exemple
Ce qui alerte les centres nerveux responsables de la respiration qu'un truc pas normal est en train de se passer
et qu'il faut aller remettre de l'ordre là-dedans.
C'est ce qu'on fait quand on bloque sa respiration
ou qu'on respire très vite dans un sac en papier mais ça perso... je ne conseille pas, c'est un coup à faire un malaise
et franchement, un malaise avec le hoquet... ça doit-être bien nul
Mais ça peut aussi consister à stimuler les nerfs en cause pour faire diversion
genre faire peur, avaler une grande cuillère de sucre, ou tirer sur sa langue vers l'avant
Non... sa propre langue
... délicatement
Des trucs du même genre, il y en a des centaines
en 2006, il y a même un médecin qui a reçu un prix IG Nobel qui récompense les recherches improbables mais sérieuses
pour son étude de cas qui cherchait à démontrer l'intérêt du toucher rectal
pour faire passer une crise de hoquet rebelle
il s'appelle Fancis Fesmire
Bon... il est décédé  mais vous imaginez si vous l'aviez eu comme médecin traitant...
- Roh docteur, depuis ce matin j'ai des migraines...
- Encore?
- Non non hein... Euh, alors, pour mon diabète par contre.
- Rho... Bon laissez tomber... Je vous dois combien?
- Pff....
Bon tous les trucs peuvent marcher pour faire passer un hoquet, même celui du Dr Fesmire a marché au moins une fois
mais ils ne marchent pas pour tout le monde
Surement comme vous, j'ai essayé un maximum de trucs sans réussir à trouver celui
qui marchait à tous les coups.
Et puis, très récemment, j'ai découvert LE truc...
En faisant des recherches dans un vieux grimoire, j'ai lu qu'un objet magique
était capable de faire passer le hoquet à tous les coups par le truchement d'un prodige
et cet objet... le voici...
c'est un glaçon
Bon alors, qu'est-ce qu'on en fait de se glaçon?
Eh bah, on se le met
- Dans ton cul
Non... Dans le nombril
Au début j'étais comme vous hein, se mettre un glaçon dans le nombril pour faire passer le hoquet
j'étais... mmh... circonspect on va dire.
Surtout que bon, quand on cherche des explication scientifiques à ça, c'est pas très convainquant
Mais j'ai quand même testé, et bah croyez le ou pas ça a marché à tous les coups
Encore mieux, pour être sur de mon coup, j'ai demandé à mon entourage de tester
Et... ça a marché, à tout les coups
Pourquoi, je parle comme ça?
Maintenant, ce que je vous propose, c'est de participer tous ensemble dans la joie et l'allégresse
à une grande expérience : la prochaine fois que vous aurez le hoquet
munissez-vous d'un glaçon et placez le dans votre nombril.
Puis faites moi savoir si ça a marché pour vous... ou pas
Vous pouvez vous filmer, c'est encore mieux.
Voilà, Dans Ton Corps c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
en attendant de faire progresser la science tous ensemble,
mangez doucement, prenez soin de vous, prenez soin des autres, et surtout, portez-vous bien!